Wouldn't it be great if we could simulate
the circuitry of the brain in a way that makes
us understand what a thought or a felling
actually is?
Or if we could diagnose diseases early, when
a disease like a cancer is in an early stage,
it's very subtly different from the normal
state?
How do you tell the difference between an
early disease and a normal tissue.
Well, with expansion microscopy, we can take
complex systems like cancers or brain circuits
and chemically inflate them until they are
a thousand times bigger in volume or even
larger.
So now we can map out the building blocks
of life and how they're organized.
We can tell you how a brain circuit looks
ideally with enough precision that let's us
simulate the function in a computer.
And we've now found that we can actually take
early cancers and tell them apart from normal
tissues which could help revolutionize disease
diagnosis early enough that lets us actually
catch diseases before they become more severe.